[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'hérite mais mon ma présentation par
quelques musique révolutionnaire et je
vais vous proposer un petit jeu vous
allez devoir essayer de trouver quelle
est cette musique
quelle est la révolution à laquelle elle
fait référence
et surtout quel peut être le rapport
avec ce que je vais vous raconter ce
soir je voudrais partager avec vous une
chance incroyable
la chance de vivre aujourd'hui une
évolution scientifique majeure la
seconde révolution quantique quantique
un mot bien étrange vous ne trouvez pas
quantique est un mot inventé par les
physiciens au début du 20e siècle pour
nommer les lois révolutionnaire qu'il
découvrait pour décrire les atomes les
électrons la matière la lumière et leur
interaction quantique vient du latin
consomment une quantité élémentaire car
dans ces nouvelles lois
les quantités comme l'énergie ou les
objets comme la lumière sont quantifiées
en grains élémentaire les comptes à
octobre 1981
paris j'ai 20 ans je descende mes
montagnes savoyardes pour gravir la
montagne sainte geneviève est rentré à
normale sup mon premier étonnement la
taille des montagnes parisienne mon
second étonnement la mécanique quantique
les profs sont fabuleuses ce sont les
futurs nobel et grand prix du cantique
je plonge dans cet univers et concertant
j'y ferai toute ma carrière de chercheur
octobre 1981
or ces masters chant et particules une
expérience nous fascine à l'institut
d'optique tout proche
un jeune chercheur alain aspect est en
train de donner raison à la mécanique
quantique contraintes stein il est en
train de prouver une propriété
incroyable de la mécanique quantique
l'intrication à distance de deux
particules la seconde révolution
quantique
était en train de montrer le bout de son
nez aujourd'hui ma priorité tout faire
pour que cette seconde révolution quand
ils deviennent une réalité pour vous
raconter cette petite histoire
laissez-moi commencer par son origine la
première révolution quantique à la fin
du 19e siècle la physique était belle et
semblait achever toutes été compris
enfin presque
la lumière qui faisait des siennes en
particulier les rayons lumineux émis par
certains corps excité ses rayons de
couleur fixe défiait toutes les lois de
la physique
pour comprendre ce mystère les meilleurs
chercheurs du début du xxème siècle
allait devoir se mettre tous ensemble
pour résoudre et proposer une nouvelle
théorie la mécanique quantique dans
cette nouvelle théorie des particules
comme l'électron sont aussi des ondes
comme les ondes à l'intérieur d'une
cavité les électrons à l'intérieur de
l'atome vibrant à des fréquences précise
excité il se désaxe it en émettant des
rayons lumineux de fréquences précise
donc de couleur fixe ainsi en mécanique
quantique les particules en sont elles
aussi des ondes et les ondes comme la
lumière sont aussi des particules on
parlait à l'époque de dualité ondes
corpuscules cette révolution de la
pensée allait dans la seconde moitié du
20e siècle et même jusqu'à aujourd'hui
révolutionner tout la technologie et
transformer notre société en société de
l'information
[Musique]
l'exemple le plus emblématique de cette
première révolution quantique de la
technologie c'est l'électronique en 1947
trois chercheurs des laboratoires bell
aux états unis invente le transistor une
sorte de porte commandable
électriquement qui laisse ou bloquent le
passage des électrons en jouant sur leur
nature quantique c'est la brique de base
pour faire des calculs ou traiter
l'information
une première information que l'on peut
codé soit par zéro soit par un fermes
ouvrent le transistor
une seconde information qui rentre à
l'entrée du transistor va être soit
bloquées soit transmise
c'est le début d'un algorithme la
miniaturisation et l'intégration d'un
nombre toujours plus grand de
transistors dans des processeurs
toujours plus puissants c'est la clé de
l'informatique moderne en 1971 le
premier processeur microprocesseurs
commercial le fameux 4004 possédait 2300
transistors leur taille quelques
centièmes de millimètre
aujourd'hui le microprocesseur everest
comporte 50 milliards de transistors
leur taille
mille fois plus petite que celle des
transistors de 1971
plus que quelques dizaines d'atomes
quand dans quelques années la taille des
transistors atteindre à celle des atomes
on ne pourra plus faire plus petit tout
s'arrêtera la puissance de calcul
atteindra un maximum et notre société
qui est maintenant basée sur
l'information recevra un coup de frein
brutal à moins que la seconde révolution
quantique ne vienne nous sauver la mise
je sais
[Musique]
pour faire de cette seconde révolution
quantique une réalité les chercheurs du
monde entier en particulier de
californie tente de dompter les
propriétés les plus remarquables les
plus extraordinaires de la mécanique
quantique
la superposition l'intrication la non
localités des propriétés tellement
étrange que même einstein n'y croyais
pas laisser moins essayer de vous faire
percevoir ces phénomènes
imaginez un lac imaginez que vous jeter
une pierre dans ce lac
plouf elle fait des ronds dans l'eau je
t'ai maintenant deux pierres une pierre
à à droite une pierre b à gauche plus
plouffe elles vont toujours des ronds
dans l'eau une série de ronds à à droite
une série de retomber à gauche à un
moment donné les deux séries de roues se
rejoignent puis se chevauchent les ondes
a et b se superposent en mécanique
quantique une particule est aussi une
onde comme les vaguelettes à la surface
de l'eau les particules peuvent être
dans un état qui est une superposition
de deux ondes a et b poussée à l'extrême
un ce raisonnement conduit au paradoxe
du chat de schrödinger qui serait à la
fois dans l'état vivants et dans l'état
mort
la non localité est une autre
conséquence de cette superposition les
états a et b peuvent être en deux lieux
différents l'un à new york l'autre à
paris enfin et c'est peut-être ça la
propriété la plus perturbante
la superposition ne se limite pas à un
système quantique seule elle est aussi
valable pour plusieurs systèmes
quantiques pris simultanément on ne peut
plus dont penser un système quantique
isolément
ils sont tous entre mêlée enchevêtrés
intriqués c'est ce que l'on appelle
l'intrication on peut plus penser le
monde de façon séparée les objet
quantique sont tous entremêlés
je comprends que cela soit difficile à
concevoir pourtant c'est une expérience
que vous pourrez faire ce soir chez vous
en rentrant sur le site web d'un grand
de l'informatique que je vais nommer
alpes et pour ne pas donner de noms de
marques en respect de la charte de tedx
vous pourrez accéder aux premières
ordinateur quantique en ligne et vous
pourrez vous même en quelques clics
intriqués ces cinq systèmes quantiques
c5 cubitt si vous préférez le réel ou
virtuel je vous ai apporté le premier
microprocesseur quantique avec deux
cubes it qui dans nos laboratoires à
saclay en 2012 a résolu un problème
simple le problème du bonneteau trouver
une bille sous 4 gobelet ce problème
paraît simple mais c'est la base des
moteurs de recherche
cette galette de silicium qui en 2016
nous a permis dans nos laboratoires à
grenoble de fabriquer le premier cubitt
en technologie silicium la technologie
des processeurs de nos ordinateurs
potentiellement dans les années à venir
cette technologie pourrait nous
permettre de fabriquer sur ce type de
galettes plusieurs puces quanti
contenant peut-être des centaines voire
des milliers de cubitt qu'est ce qu'un
cube it
qu'est ce qu'un ordinateur quantique
qu'est ce qu'un processeur quantique
parce que j'en parle depuis un certain
temps mais finalement je voulais pas
défini un cube it c'est simplement un
système quantique qui possède deux états
un bébé traditionnellement nous les
appelons plus tôt 0 et 1
par analogie avec les beats de nos
ordinateurs classiques dans le monde
classique un bit n'a que deux
possibilités soit ils vont 0 soit il
vaut 1 dans le monde quantique un cubitt
un concours bits à une infinité de
possibilités toutes les superpositions
entre l'état zéro
elle est à un plus fort avec ses 5
cubitt le petit ordinateur alpes et que
vous trouvez sur le web 1 possède déjà
trente deux étant deux états pour le
premier que 8 x 2 pour
deuxième qubits x 2 pour le troisième
fois deux pour le quatrième fois de pour
le 5ème égale 32 et 1 vous pourrez donc
superposés c 32 est à 32 infinité de
possibilités encore plus fort
l'ordinateur alpes et peu transformés
simultanément les 32 états trente deux
calculent en parallèle une puissance de
calcul qui pourrait devenir quasi
infinie car le nombre d'états double
chaque fois que vous rajoutez un seul
cubitt c'est la légende de 6,1 il ya
très longtemps dans un royaume lointain
un roi indien chira main s'ennuyait
ferme son grand vizir sis à ben dahir
inventant un nouveau jeu
les échecs le roi fut enchanté quelle
récompense où es tu pour ce jeu
merveilleux demanda le roi je suis un
homme simple répondit 6 1 juste un grain
de blé sur la première case de
l'échiquier 2 sur la suivante 4 sur la
troisième
8 sur la 4ème et ainsi de suite jusqu'à
la dernière la 64e en doublant le nombre
de grains de blé à chaque case le roi
accepte a immédiatement ce qu'il pensait
être une bonne affaire sans se rendre
compte qu'il faudrait un silo de 10
kilomètres de large et de 10 kilomètres
de haut pour contenir le blé de la 64e
case et milan de la production mondiale
pour le remplir un ordinateur quantique
avec 64 cubitt posséderait autant
d'états qui lie à de grains de blé sur
l'échiquier de s'y sent tellement
d'étain que cet ordinateur de 6 à battre
est tous les super calculateurs du monde
et sa puissance doublerait chaque fois
que l'on ajouterait un simple cubitt
mais nous n'en sommes pas là
la route est encore longue et semée
d'embûches nos cubitt sont encore très
imparfait ils perdent rapidement leur
nature quantique pour corriger ses
erreurs il faudrait des milliers de
qubits physique pour produire un cube it
logiq parfait des processeurs avec des
milliers voire des millions de cubes it
vont rencontrer des difficultés
conceptuelles et technologique qu'on ne
connaît pas encore heureusement la
communauté scientifique se mobilisent et
les états et les gaffes à main
investissent massivement alors pour
quelques instants
rêvons
[Musique]
une puissance de calcul
coisy infinie des moteurs de recherche
sans limite d intelligence artificielle
décuplée de nouveaux médicaments conçus
incanto mme szili qu une médecine
personnalisée
une recherche simulant la physique la
chimie la vie des capteurs aux
performances ultimes capable de détecter
des molécules uniques de diagnostiquer
des maladies de façon précoce de
découvrir de nouvelles ressources
d'explorer l'univers la matière le temps
la vie des communications inviolable des
lasers de matières et peut-être même la
téléportation quantique
rien n'est certain mais tout est
possible mais le plus fabuleux le plus
fabuleux c'est que nous pouvons suivre
aujourd'hui en direct cette révolution
scientifique majeure nous pouvons même y
participer
alors ne boudons pas notre plaisir
vivons là pleinement avec passion tout
en sachant raison garder merci
[Applaudissements]